hey everybody welcome back to the John
and jenni show this is episode number
two okay somebody's dancing I'm your
host Jon Corey founder of liquid calm
and the author of a new book chronology
coming out soon and with me is Jenny
moon hello I'm calling from New York
City a media coach they're making you a
star in your life and in the media so
happy to be here again John thanks for
being with us Jenny Wow and this show is
all about cool people doing cool things
we want to show our audience how people
achieve the things they want to achieve
in their lives and today we've got Evan
Carmichael with us from ww Evan
Carmichael calm spell just like you
think and he's going to show us how to
build up your YouTube following evan has
built up a nice YouTube following and
hopefully he's going to take us through
the steps to to get that and so we're
going to show you a clip of Evan right
now with one of his youtube videos yes
clip Jenny rolling the cliff I'm the
technical person with me here we go this
is one of my favorite clips of evan i
love it i think it speaks for itself how
to get through hard times a buddy of
mine is going through a hard time in his
life right now and i sent him a message
today to encourage him and to support
him and I realized that what I wrote in
that message i I've never really shared
with people before it I haven't shared
it with you and I thought that the
message you might help you if you're
going through a hard time in your life
right now and it's sharing my story from
what happened to me last year last year
was a really hard year for me both from
a business perspective and in a personal
perspective on the business side I was
growing less and less happy with what i
was doing most of my money came from
advertising I had a popular website at
over 20 million people visit my site and
so you can sell advertising against that
and make money from it the problem for
me there was I was creating content that
would just generate a lot of you
so it could sell a lot of advertising
and it wasn't necessarily stuff that I
was proud of or would really help
entrepreneurs which was my passion and
so it felt increasingly disconnected
from my business and as a result last
year totally changed my model took off
all the odds of my sight and took my
biggest revenue source and brought it to
zero which was really stressful and
basically was starting over starting
over with a new business model to help
entrepreneurs on a personal level my
life was falling apart in a lot of
different areas I went through a divorce
which was the most stressful thing that
I've ever had to go through in my life
and and I hope that you never have to go
through that I i spent 1.6 million
dollars building my dream house and then
had to sell it I basically cost so did
make a profit on it I I gained 15 pounds
and for the first time in my life had to
watch what I was eating and pay
attention to that where I never had to
worry before I started losing my hair
for the first time in my life too from
all the stress and craziness and people
my family you know passed away and not
created more stress and it was I was a
tough year and it's funny how in life
sometimes when when something is going
wrong everything seems to go wrong at
once and just when you think something
is you know you're just getting better
something hits you in the stomach even
harder that's kind of how the pattern
goes and the advice that I gave to my
friend was what helped me get through it
because it was a really challenging
tough year but what helped me get
through was feeling like I was doing
something important it was making these
videos helping you guys answering your
questions feeling like I was giving back
and helping people so the only way that
I knew how which is to entrepreneurship
and by helping you guys and by seeing
the responses on the videos and by
knowing that I'd help your business get
better I've help you become a better
entrepreneur on your route taking that
knowledge and and helping more people
that making me feel like I was doing
something important
okay so you get the gist huh I get the
gist I'm pretty moved by that to be
quite all right how is he that's a great
example so it's pretty impressive yeah
well let's bring Evan on let's have it
is he done with his uh is he ready for
us Evan Carmichael come on Evan I do
have to say that was a pretty courageous
video do you want to tell us about that
oh you're on mute buddy hold on a sec am
I do I have him on mute and then oh yeah
okay um yeah that was a pretty raw one
um a buddy of mine was going through
something basically pretty similar he
was in a divorce and his business was
falling apart and and I just wrote him
an email to let him know that hey I went
through the same thing and here's how I
became in and he was so overwhelmed with
that that I thought hey I should I gotta
share this and help other people who
might be going for the same thing and so
did all this start when you as you said
am I am I the people hear me yep don't
let start when you said you took down
all that advertising off your site and
you started to make the videos is that
where this real change came in your in
your whole YouTube sort of thing or this
was the beginning of your YouTube things
when you stop with the ads on your site
and started making the videos now that
wasn't the start um I was growing more
and more dissolution with my website and
as a result I was trying to I started
doing videos as my passion outlet and so
I spent my time there where my team was
spending time on the website and I
started doing the videos because I got a
lot of questions that people were asking
me and I would always just mind my email
and I spent a lot of time writing the
people back on email okay I don't get
anything from it other than personal
satisfaction um but I figured that you
know if these people had this question
other people would have the same and if
I made a video that I could help them as
well as help a lot of other
people had that same question that was
the start of the video channel and been
working with this awesome connection
coach in Jenny moon who's helped me make
the videos a lot better and she
encouraged me to take risks and be
vulnerable and that was part of what you
know that Claude came out in that video
that we just saw OE will really gives us
a nice that video is one of my favorite
videos because it exemplifies why so
many people love Evan Carmichael they
believe in him because he speaks with
such truth vulnerability and heart and
that is in contrast to a lot of this
stuff that you see on websites and stuff
where people are sort of producing
content that they know is just gonna
kind of prickle people and just bring in
good SEO or whatever bring in a lot of
visitors but doesn't really offer a
whole lot of stuff I guess that is a big
contrast right there yeah and even you
look at SEO it's moving towards brands
it's less about the keywords and more
about the brains and so hobby build up I
don't know who your audience is if
they're entrepreneurs anybody up the
personal brand how can you build up a
corporate brain that connects with
people right if you can make that
connection people you're gonna get
hormones and you're gonna get the SEO so
now SEO isn't about keywords it's about
building up yourself as a brand and this
is this is a great strategy to help how
does that how does that work can you
explain that a little bit cuz what do
people go to google and then they
because normally we go to google news
search for stuff like entrepreneurship
and they would come up with a site sarya
one of the results would be your site
then for instance yeah but no tip it I
google used to be very keyword focus and
and the common advice was you know
create content with these keywords or by
the skull that exact match domain you
know you want the domain with your
keywords in it so you want you know
entrepreneur website calm so you can
bring it on our website was moving far
away from that now where they realize so
many people were just scanning the
results Google's really what they want
is they want follow the information you
want their people you want searches to
be happy right if I type in whatever
search I want to be satisfied with the
result and google has over the past
number of years really updated their
algorithm to focus on working
and showing companies that are they
consider bigger brands even if they
don't have as much keyword optimization
right because a total presence oh my god
yeah everyone is going to know like
everyone because everyone America the
world wants to know because you just
said it right we all have to build our
personal brand John the John and jenni
show we're building our personal brand
on this show you're helping
entrepreneurs build their personal brand
how do they do it through YouTube how do
they how where are your tips is this a
great tip already just said I think it's
a great idea is the fact that a lot of
people get a lot of email a lot of
people the people would like following
to get a lot of emails and I feel like
that is in a sense of waste it's not a
waste of time in a sense but you're not
maximizing that content because you're
putting good content into an email so I
have even considered the idea when you
respond to emails post them all on your
website and you're basically doing that
in a sort of sense but through YouTube
videos yeah and I think people I'm a
visual learner I think most people are
visual learners and if you can see a
picture and you can see that person
talking to you it helps them understand
your message better than just reading it
and it ties into you I get so many
people write to me and they say you know
Evan thank you so much I feel like I've
known you and they bring up something
that I might have said in my videos and
the first time it happened it's kind of
creepy like well they're calling me
their friend and they're bringing up
stuff from my past and and like I have
nobody who you are uh but I got more and
more used to it but it you know if
you're just getting started on YouTube I
how I start with just answering
questions so you know you may not even
have an audience yet and you're just
trying to get started so you know you
don't have people are asking you
questions yet but you can think about
your interactions with your customers
and prospects and people in your network
and the common problems that they have
and use that as a question say if
something that happened and start
sharing and the first step is really
just providing a helpful advice
where my video started getting a lot
better was injecting and this is you
know big credit to Jenny for helping
with this is injecting your story and uh
you know your passion into the video so
if somebody asked me how do I you know
how do i do a steal for my company I
would get on say okay who's are you SEO
and I'm comfortable talking about the
topic and I here are the five things you
need to do paw paw paw paw paw and
that's great that's great content but it
doesn't Thai people to me yet and what
really adds to it is me sharing my story
to about SEO and the pains that I went
through and showing a little bit of
vulnerability basically getting people
to feel something right I want people to
see every video that I create and feel
something because that ties them to my
brain and makes me want to watch another
video and another video another and I
guess I guess you said the right word
their little keyword in all this is a
process so you said it's kind of weird
was kind of creepy at first that people
start to I'll take what was creepy for
me because I also worked with Jenny the
first thing is weird is to just bring
yourself in the first place just film
yourself that is the weirdest thing in
the world is it not but apparently you
used to know yeah ah question even
answer that because John I remember in
the beginning it had issues around
filming and a lot of people do a lot of
people that's one of the main reasons
why they don't even started YouTube
channel how do you overcome this
obstacle to phenomena seeing yourself on
camera it's scary it's so scary and and
your first video suck like it's just
knowing that your video is going to suck
and it's a process and they'll get
better you know my first video I didn't
want to spend money on a camera so I
used my DSLR but it didn't focus
properly so it didn't autofocus I had to
have somebody focus it for me so I had
my sister I had some of my staff come in
to the room focused it and then leave
because I couldn't have them in the room
while I was doing the video becomes too
you know not even like me on anybody
else in the room right it was too too
scary the first videos that I did it
took me like the whole thing the whole
day to do one vid
yo and and the video sucked you know is
decent content whatever but it wasn't
anything that I'm massively proud of I
still put it up and I got some good
feedback on it I look at that video and
you can see it on my channel if you go
back to the beginning and I'm
embarrassed by I look at that oh man I
want to take that down it's so bad but
people still like it and it's fun to see
kind of the progress that you made now
i'm at the point where i've got i don't
know I've got 1,200 videos recorded a
hundred videos yeah man it's it's so you
gotten use to it is that you telling us
I'll sit down on a Wednesday and I'll
film between 10 to 20 videos on one
wednesday afternoon what before that
used to take me out what yeah why I mean
cuz look so you got a five steps for SEO
or whatever but 1200 videos that's a
lotta yeah what are we talking about
then it's a lot of work native so you've
gotten really creative in your videos
now to your showing all sides of who you
are why yeah most of the videos so and
this is for those are you looking at a
video strategy there's a great one that
YouTube suggests called hero and hygiene
where hero is your big videos that's the
one that you you know you're hoping goes
viral you're big you know thought
provoking you to spend a lot of time
working on night one Vidya that has
almost half a million views that we
spend a lot of time on i shouldna hiney
is your daily stuff right like you brush
your teeth every day you wash your face
every day so the hygiene is daily
regular content that you put up on your
site where the hero is maybe once a year
every six months so let me get that down
brush your teeth yes every day I got
that now hey here we go Marvin Johnson
your teeth your life's potential diapers
yeah John just had a baby so you can
show you can shoot I whole video series
on being it a dad for the third time now
actually what I found was the the
hygiene content most of it is answering
people's questions so hey I got a great
question from John from Arizona
here's this question and an answer
that's most of it but on top of that
i'll also add some fun videos i have a
series are called the raw series where
I'm upset about something and it in the
moment I'll pull out my phone and just
record something the quality sucks on it
but it's a passionate message coming out
I'm a film something fun I just did some
organic sprouting for the first time so
I'm filming myself going through that
process like I'm learning so you're
learning with me as the audience don't
message Evan that you're pointing out is
that you get people to fall in love with
you because you are showing so many
different sides of who you are you're
not just showing this one-dimensional
Evan you're showing all these dimensions
of you and so then you build a following
and those videos are more for the
hardcore audience so i did a video like
Evan goes to Florida and I took my
family to Orlando we went on all the
rides and we're singing the songs all
that stuff and there's some funny
moments in there but like why would you
watch that Evans vacation video like who
cares about as that how many people are
watching this stuff so those videos
don't get as many views as the how to
pull knowledge stuff but the people who
watch it are the hard core audience and
then they want to go out and watch more
because I've brought them in so they
feel really connect it to me and then
they want to go watch everything else
and so most of the views that I get on
my videos are a related video so they
watch one and then they watch another
one and another one and another one so
they keep watching more and more of my
videos and subscribe and then new ones
come out to keep watching those so it's
it's good to have a mix of the of the
personal ones in there as well um and
it's up to you how much you want to
share like I don't get too deep and
personal to some of the stuff but um you
know eighty percent eighty-five percent
is straight up business stuff with my
stories and in that extra 15 20 is going
to be the fun fun side of me and it
brings people and it makes them feel
like they know this guy and when they're
looking for business advice they're
going to come to me instead of somebody
else would your friends think of all
this is what I'm thinking what do your
friends think of that a lot of them
wanted
to do it really that's real yeah they
want help and I've helped a few people
through the process um some of them have
been on the videos like when I went to
Orlando I went with a friend of mine and
he's on some of the videos and I know
they're used to it by now I guess too um
I am an artist too i think of that it's
fun so it's so Evan her for our for all
the Evan fans out there for all the
entrepreneurs for all the people who are
wanting to build their brand on their
YouTube channel what are some specific
nuts and bolts hips that someone
starting out can do because I know like
you're very consistent you you have a
whole little you know bag of tricks of
things that you do that have gotten you
success what are those tips so so let me
start with a quick story so I'm at so
the to market media's if you know the
client would Jenny's been working with
me on helping my videos and when I first
talked to them the owner he tells me
Evan I don't think you're going to be a
good fit for our channel because uh
you've got great content but you kind of
suck on camera and like what are you
what I thought it was good on camera man
everybody thumb like 500 videos how
could I suck on camera and he said you
know most people we get are there
already media coach they already on CNN
they're already on CNBC there were these
experts and so he he took a fire on me
and we started working together and
that's when I met Jenny and we started
working together and from that point I
started doing two videos every day like
two videos go up on my channel every
single day of the week and through crazy
repetition and building that muscle and
getting advice and feedback I've make
the videos better to the point where now
they're my channels being referenced as
a best practice where these other people
have a hard time posting once a week
Here I am now the best case scenario for
people to model like are you kidding me
I was like the worst person three months
ago I also wasn't have accepted in and
now it's the best one
it's just through a lot of work that we
got there but to Janie's question of
specific steps of what you can do the
first one is figure what your story is
and you don't have to be a super
outgoing person like I'm actually really
shy person you may not you may not get
that with a head doctor to me right now
but I'm not the guy who goes up in these
people advance and introduces myself and
ends up my business card and Fox League
on the airplane That's not me um but you
gotta get just because you're shy it
doesn't mean you're not passionate about
what you're doing so it's figuring out
how to tell your story in the passionate
way so like work on the first video
that's your very first video practical
hands-on steps make your first video
that tells your story why you do what
you do what made you start this thing
that you're doing why it means something
to you and don't worry if it's not
edited properly and you know don't worry
about any of that stuff it can be off
your phone right don't let these excuses
get the way if you get it started does
your first one and then regular
consistent videos and think about
problems that people are facing
questions that you could ask from your
customers or from your friends or
prospects or if you're hanging out in
chats and you see people talking about
something or there's something in the
news that you have an opinion on create
a quick video the tops above that and
just get in the habit put it in your
schedule once a week or whatever it is
set aside time this is my video
production day and know that your first
ones are going to suck and that's okay
and you're going to be nervous and
that's okay and you're gonna get better
they're going to get better each time
and once you start seeing feedback come
in somebody says wow great video it
makes you feel so good like the best
part of my day is waking up I grab my
lentils for breakfast and spinach and
lentils start mixing them together and I
start looking at my comments some
YouTube and it's always all these great
wonderful things and that just gets me
all geared up for the day ahead so I
give a lot of tips I've kind of rambled
but you want a tip so tell your story
right tell your story
schedule it in once a week set aside
time know that they're going to suck and
that's okay and don't be too worried
about them being super professionally
done and what has it gotten you because
you've gotten some accolades not only
the awesome comments but your youtube
channel has gotten you some gigs right
yeah um I recent came back from Malaysia
where I was asked to do a speech on
social media and Malaysia yeah they
awarded me social media speaker of the
year something i don't know i don't even
know how they found out about me um and
i asked him like yeah that's what they
said right i asked them and i dunno i
don't know any Malaysians I have no
Malaysia connections and they flew me
over there and paid my fee and hotel and
airfare and all that stuff and they said
they just found me through my youtube
videos and said we gotta get this guy
here and that works so these people just
write to you and say we want you to come
speak yeah and you had no idea who they
were right there but they feel like they
know me from watching all my videos Wow
and how did you find out they were legit
maybe I'm going too deep into this i
mean no it's cool y'all curiosity good
questions um before I booked anything in
my calendar they don't come you know
they're going over they're gonna kill
you or something you know I gonna look
like naughty or something right uh and
it did look kind of sketchy and I was
worried you know some opportunity but
before I booked anything in I need to
get a deposit and for my speaking gig
that's at least fifty percent up front
so they wired the money into my bank
account and that was the first steps
like okay these guys at brio they pay my
trust yeah yeah uh I need it has spurred
I mean all of this has happened because
of his YouTube channel is following he
got this amazing workshop and now
they're just coming right it's all it's
like a snowball effect all because of
his passionate videos yeah yeah I'm
doing another one next month in orlando
at a national conference for a company
and again they just family through
my youtube channel one of the guys who's
going to be attending their recommended
it to the CEO of the company and have a
call with him and saw my videos too and
deals are just happening people are just
finding it from the audience that I've
built wow it's amazing evyn thank you so
much for joining us um how can people
get in touch with you uh Evan Carmichael
com that's the website you can find me
on youtube the channel is modeling the
Masters and you'll find you'll find me
you can't miss him love these videos you
can't miss those Evan nie 70 much really
you're an inspiration your passion your
vulnerability your creativity and what
you're doing on YouTube is absolutely
amazing top notch thanks for being here
buddy thanks guys Evan Carmichael
everybody hang on with us we're gonna
have a little talk bye bye Evan by Evan
show hey we're back we weren't there the
whole time but that's okay I mean he's a
star of the show I love that guy he is
doing I can see why you saw on that
video he has so much heart and passion
for what he is is trying to do in
helping entrepreneurs and I think like
that's the most important thing you just
have to have you've got people have to
know that you care that's a great tip
that gives though I think about being
shy in everything cuz I think some
people just feel like you're totally not
made for this I'm shy your winner here
Vince your video series coming out John
she's making me think about that stuff
should I can't do that but the point
what he says is is that ok you're shy or
whatever but you got to find that
passion inside and say okay well that's
coming out in this form you know it
despite that and and this is something I
struggle with a lot is that high whole
idea that it's gonna suck and you got to
get used to it and so that was a big
thing too so what's your first video
gonna be coming out chronology know so I
do have a book cover Oh apply it when
I'm in the shower I should just take
videos in the shower because I want I'm
in the shower i'm a genius i'm a
speaking wizard that's when you're like
totally relax and everything comes but
um I don't know see I don't know
I'll have a million excuses why not to
do it but it probably is right you
probably should just do this sort of
thing right you have to just do it you
have to just do it because if you don't
then you know you're going to come up
with excuse after excuse missed
opportunities yep but I've really
enjoyed this get used to it figure out
your story all these great tips I just
disappeared frozen your friends and John
you're frozen in TV land you're frozen
so so John we can't end until you commit
to one video which one is it going to be
um I'm gonna introduce a book how's that
sound awesome I just did a video before
we did our show so I have that one so
all right so you're gonna do a video on
your book I'm gonna do a video on the
book all right Evan Carmichael thank you
because we this was inspired by you yeah
thanks Evan for coming on the show we're
gonna post the transcript of this on the
website on one of our websites will post
it on YouTube and an on google+
everybody thanks for coming in jan you
want to roll the uh thank you thanks for
visiting us see you soon